you know i hope netflix recovers
hulu and chill just doesn't have the
same ring to it
[Music]
hey there folks uh
so uh this is another case where
something has happened that i'm like i
i have thoughts on that i'm gonna talk
about that and this time we're talking
about
netflix
netflix has had
about about week and a half by the time
this actually goes live at time of
recording they've had a bad
five days
but um
they
issued a quarterly report to their
investors
having to admit to the fact
that they lost subscribers globally for
the first time
in 10 years
and their stock
plunged
i'll get into some of the specifics of
the numbers in a little bit
but this
this begs a lot of questions
how did this happen
why is it so sudden
what happens next
and was this kind of inevitable spoiler
on that last one
yeah it was although the timing uh
wasn't necessarily inevitable the event
was though but we'll build up to that we
gotta lay some groundwork first okay
let's talk about what happened
on
4 20
of all days
netflix had its quarterly update on how
the first quarter of 2022 went and told
its investors about the fact that they
lost 200 000 subscribers globally
now that's actually not that many
considering how huge netflix is but as i
said this was the first time they'd ever
lost subscribers basically since they
became a streaming service
so
the results on that
were immediate
by the close of business on the 20th
their stock had settled at a 35
drop
and this despite the fact that netflix
came in with explanations for why
numbers went down plans for how they
were going to try and raise numbers and
up revenue they like it's not like they
went we don't know what happened they
knew what happened they were upfront
about it didn't matter
there's some quirks to the stock market
i'll bring that up a little bit it is
worth noting though that while this was
what grabbed all the headlines this is
not netflix's first big
stock plunge
it's not even their first big stock
plunge this year
at the end of trading on the 21st of
january they were down 22 percent now i
couldn't exactly nail down what the heck
happened on that date um i probably
could if i kept searching but
the specifics honestly didn't matter but
the fact that this wasn't their first
major drop
that does kind of matter and more than
that
they've actually been declining for a
little bit
netflix hit its peak its highest stock
price
in november but ever since then it has
been going down now these drops were
really huge and it had just been kind of
more steadily declining prior to that
because
well
reality has been catching up with
netflix and prior to november of last
year they had been steadily going up
basically since their creation
but that that train ride appears to be
over
so let's talk about
what happened
the first thing is there was a very
direct and immediate impact which is
that netflix cut off its service to
russia in a response to what is going on
in ukraine which is something a lot of
companies did they stopped doing
business in russia and for netflix that
meant 700 000 subscribers immediately
gone now if you're going well okay so
that count that accounts for the 200 000
it does
uh but it's a little bit more
complicated than that because
they weren't projecting to be flat they
weren't projecting any kind of loss
they had been projecting growth
more to the point they had projected to
grow two and a half million subscribers
in quarter one this year so even if they
hadn't shut off russia and lost those
700 000 while they wouldn't have been
down globally
and like that became the big headline
but like that wouldn't have happened if
it hadn't been for the russia thing but
even if that hadn't happened
they still came
way short
of the growth that they were supposed to
do and they're now projecting a loss of
another 2 million subscribers
now despite this revenue is actually up
10 i'm not entirely sure how but that's
what's been reported it's currently
sitting at 7.87 billion but even that
despite being up 10 is shy of what it's
supposed to be it was supposed to go up
to
7.93 billion and that's revenue that's
not profit profit is down their profit
had been 1.7 billion annually it's now
down to 1.6
now
this is where i need to get into some of
the
oddities and stupidity of the stock
market and yes i'm gonna say stupidity
i've talked about businesses
entertainment corporations etc multiple
times on this channel over the years
i've even talked about you know massive
scrambles reorganizations i don't talk
stock price
i don't do it for a number of reasons
the big ones being i think the stock
market is stupid
it's gambling that for some idiotic
reason we have tied massive swaths of
the economy to
but beyond that what i really want you
to understand accepting that i'm not a
stock market expert but here's something
that like is really important to to wrap
your head around
the stock market doesn't
respond to reality
it responds to the perception
of reality
and perception is
really easy to uh manipulate
as is evidenced by the letter that
netflix itself sent out to its investors
in a company letter they noted that the
covid bump to not only netflix but all
streaming services in 2020 and 2021
basically papered over existing flaws
that were already there and didn't go
away with the big subscriber bump they
were just waiting for the bump to no
longer offset them
so the reality has been netflix has been
in trouble for a bit now actually
but it's only when the perception
finally gets shattered that their stock
drops and it's why it drops suddenly in
a day as opposed to gradually over time
even though it was also doing that
but
stocks are
as i said they're idiotic and the other
thing that you need to realize is i
noted you know profit revenue growth
here's the other thing you really need
to understand
and again i'm boiling this way the hell
down but
at some point in your life if you
haven't already you're going to realize
that
whatever fundamental
notions of economics you might have
learned in school the idea of well you
make more money than you spend that's
profit so you're a profitable business
that's good that's not the economic
reality we live in not when investors
get involved investors don't want profit
they want growth it is not enough to
make more money than it costs to run
your business every year that is not
enough you have to make more money than
you made last year every single year if
not every single quarter you're expected
to make more and more and more because
that's where stock value is stock value
on a stable company like it's just
steadily moving along it's got
consistent um
revenue it's got consistent profit it's
totally stable that's worthless stock
stock is only worth money if it keeps
going up and the only way to make it go
up is to bring in more more more more
year after year every year i had my
wake-up call on this at um it wasn't my
first job but it was the first job that
i kind of like took seriously and was
like i'll probably i might be at this
for a little while i worked at a barnes
noble
out of college
and
i remember
it was i think we just wrapped up the
year and the like the regional manager
or somebody barnes and noble had come in
now i realize this was back before
e-readers so barnes noble was doing
pretty well um and he came in and he
told us you folks just had the best year
that this location has ever had
and then in the very next breath he said
but you were behind what you were
projected to do so you've got a lot of
making up to do this is not okay we're
not happy with
this think about that contradiction this
is the best this location has ever done
but it wasn't the growth we projected
so it's not good enough it's bad
that was an immediate
wake-up call to me
on the reality of things and i had that
hammered into me again in the job that i
had before i was lucky enough to be able
to have this be my living which was that
i worked in sales and every year i had
to give a projection for what i expected
my sales numbers to be
and every year i had the same back and
forth which is i made a realistic
projection of what i actually
realistically thought i could do maybe
even cushion a little more thinking well
maybe i'll get lucky and do a little bit
better than i think and then every year
it will come back and they'd say this
has to be a hundred thousand dollars
higher this has to we have to round this
up to the next million this has to be
more and i always had effectively the
same conversation which is so you want
me to lie to you
because you want me to put down a number
that i don't think i can hit simply
because that's what you have to tell
investors to keep them happy
because this is the thing you have to
realize investors have not only more
power more clout they have also way more
protections than consumers do certainly
than employees do
capitalism sucks if you weren't aware
but anyways let's get into this a little
bit more
so with something like netflix i said
they were always going to have this
problem because
there's a limited number of people on
the planet just logistically eventually
you are going to have everyone who can
be subscribed to you subscribe to you
and if you're thinking well they've got
like what 200 some odd million
subscribers there's almost 8 billion
people on this planet they've got plenty
of room for growth yeah but okay
let's actually break that down because
it's not every single person that is a
viable customer it has to be someone who
has reliable electricity a television
internet access internet access that is
high enough speed to be able to do
streaming they have to be able to afford
that internet access they have to have
enough disposable income to be able to
afford the monthly fee of netflix they
have to have the desire for what netflix
is offering them
this is
a lot this is uh
going to severely narrow down the actual
viable pool of people
who could be purchasing their service
so
they were always eventually going to hit
the ceiling this is actually the reality
of any company this is a big part of why
companies when they get to a certain
size just start acquiring other
companies
this is why disney does things like buy
marvel
or buy pixar
because
they have kind of hit the ceiling
on the growth of
the disney brand itself
like these parks
can only get so much bigger
the revenue from
the various disney channels and from the
released disney films
it's gotten about as high as it can get
and while maybe they can keep tweaking a
little bit that growth is gonna slow the
way to energize it is to buy something
that has more potential for growth
than what their current assets are so
you buy marvel you buy star wars and you
grow those because those have more room
to grow but eventually everything hits a
ceiling
eventually everything whether it be a
case of look
as many people as are ever going to want
this have already bought it or whether
it's a case of consumers are sick of it
whatever the reason eventually every
product every brand every ip hits a
ceiling
investors don't care
when you hit that ceiling that's when
they bail and that's where companies
start
taking on water and
things like this happen
now has netflix truly hit its ceiling
i don't know
probably not but
let's also be clear netflix has been
doing some questionable things netflix
has been actively running up debt
for a long time
up until last year netflix was borrowing
billions
all the time last year they stopped they
finally stopped acquiring new debt
now
this is not necessarily criticism of
them initially running with debt because
i mean to do what they were planning to
do they needed startup funds and there's
what you get from investors and the like
but also sometimes you need really
liquid income right now you need stuff
that you can work with if you're going
to get all these license deals to have
all these things if you're going to
start making your own original content
if you are going to be hosting the
servers for all this content to be able
to even up and run yes they needed the
money but they kept borrowing and they
kept borrowing very large sums for a
very long time until they just kind of
stopped
now out of guess
stopping last year like they did
i uh
strongly suspect that they realized that
the day of reckoning was coming
and the worst thing that they could do
was run up more debt
when they weren't sure that they were
going to be able to maintain the kind of
growth that they had of course they were
still projecting to their investors that
they would keep maintaining that growth
because like
maybe you'll get lucky and you will hit
that growth
you almost never tell investors that
you're going to
lose money in the next quarter
unless it is an absolute definite fact
but i strongly suspect netflix despite
their projections that they were gonna
gain two and a half million subscribers
in quarter one this year i suspect that
they probably knew that wasn't gonna
happen
they were just hoping
because maybe a miracle would happen
maybe they'd get there
it didn't and now they have to own up to
we're probably going to lose another 2
million because that sounds like a real
sudden thing to happen i don't know it's
like no they knew this was coming they
just weren't going to admit it until
there was no way for them to hide from
that fact and they've now hit that point
there's also some questions about
netflix's spending netflix has been
throwing a lot of money around in the
last few years they have been
deliberately courting
major hollywood talent with the likes of
michael bay zack snyder they've been
doing oscar push they started winning
oscars in 2017 and have reliably picked
up a couple every year since
the upcoming season of stranger things
they spent 30
million
dollars
per episode
nine episodes that's 270 million dollars
they spent the production budget of
batman v superman dawn of justice on one
season
of stranger things
a show that bile indication
is ending
and anyone who is going to be subscribed
for the sake of stranger things
probably already is
and like keep in mind i don't make that
comparison to batman v superman idly
when that movie failed to make a billion
dollars at the box office one of the
largest entertainment corporations in
the world went into a freaking panic
warner brothers was scrambling trying to
figure out what went wrong and how to
fix it over
something that they made with that kind
of budget and netflix threw it at one
season of television
netflix has a number of things that it's
kind of been battling with for a while
but it's been managed to kick these cans
down the road
for one thing i talked about the
limitations for their actual viable
subscriber bases you know places that
have the internet the economic resources
you know the streaming capacity et
cetera et cetera et cetera there's
another thing they can't just start
dropping their movies into theaters to
try and get more money that way they
would love to
don't get me wrong but the thing is most
theater chains won't carry netflix films
not because they can't because they
won't
because theater chains
hate
netflix they hate anything that makes
the home viewing experience a viable
substitution for going to the movies now
granted kovet threw this all out of
whack and we had some very strange
things like when warner brothers took
every single movie that they were
planning to release in uh 2021 and
release it simultaneously on streaming
and in theaters and boy did that tick
off like everybody in the business world
when they did that so like things have
been weird the last few years but even
before that netflix can't get their
stuff into theaters so they can't grow
that way so how can they grow
well this is where we get into some
other stuff that came out uh when they
had to announce their numbers and talk
to investors about what they were going
to do
they are now talking about adding a less
expensive subscription price that would
include ads
so there's that and they're talking
about cracking down on shared passwords
so this kind of illustrates in many ways
what happens when a company hits the
natural ceiling of their product but
still needs to continue growth
because
for years
netflix has not had to run ads
netflix didn't really care
about password sharing between
households
because they didn't have to
now these actually became massive
selling points for the company they were
nice bonuses they were oh
they they don't have ads on this well
that's great there shouldn't be we're
paying for it flat out so yeah there
shouldn't be ads but you know also they
don't crack down on this thing oh that's
nice
they didn't crack down on it because
they could afford not to
well they can't afford not to anymore
so despite as
consumer-friendly a thing as it would be
to simply just let it slide as they have
been they can't afford to be
consumer-friendly anymore
because as i said they're they've either
hit or
within sight of the natural ceiling of
how many people are actually going to
get subscribed so what has to happen now
is figuring out how to maybe get a few
more people in at a lower price with ads
i would not be shocked
if the ads thing
if it doesn't bring in that much
that what they end up doing instead
is making ads the default on the current
price and creating a premium to get rid
of them kind of like what youtube
premium is i would not be surprised at
all because i can't imagine they're
going to get that many new people with
this subscription but with ads model
so i would not be shocked if in a year
two years they force it
they take the current subscription
price and say okay at that you also have
ads you don't want the ads give us more
money
and the other way they're going to make
more money out of their subscriber base
in theory is to crack down on household
password sharing now they claim
that there are a hundred million
households that are using a shared
password
i don't know how they came up with that
i but
we're not going to get into methodology
let's just assume for the time being
that it's true
they have the potential to be making the
same mistake that people make when they
claim that piracy hurts the box office
returns of a movie they are making the
assumption
that every stolen or borrowed account
is
a lost sale much like how
industry advocates will claim that every
pirated copy of a movie a video game etc
is a lost sale
that's not the reality well it's
definitely not the reality for piracy at
any rate studies have shown that most
people who pirate if they can't get
something through privacy they'll get
something else
it's not that they will pay to get the
thing they'll just go pirate something
similar that they can get
uh at least uh that's enough of a
percentage that like you definitely
can't assume these are all lost sales
some of them sure
not all
probably not even most and i wouldn't be
surprised if that ends up being this the
situation with shared passwords as well
because this is another thing netflix
has hit its ceiling
but a lot of its other rivals haven't
i'm not sure hulu has disney plus
probably hasn't hbo max hasn't
and if other
services don't have to start cracking
down on password sharing
well maybe if you've been sharing
somebody's netflix password
you give it up and just share their
disney plus password instead
or you just share their hbo max or their
amazon prime
or what have you now
we go far enough down the road
eventually all of these will hit a
ceiling or they will simply decide
collectively that as an industry we're
going to make this the new standard that
happens sometimes that happened in like
say for instance the airline industry
i forget which uh airline started it but
when they started
uh charging for checked bags that didn't
used to be a thing
um and and then they started charging
like for even your first checked bag and
then that sort of thing became the
standard not because they had to but
because when other airlines realized oh
if we all do it
then we'll all get a piece of it instead
of saying hey we don't do that as a
selling point they all went well let's
all get a piece of that pie let's all do
it
so that could potentially happen
but until it does
this is going to be a knock on netflix
because netflix now looks
less consumer friendly
which they're going to have to because
as i said consumers don't actually
matter
the investors do consumers only matter
and so far as they keep the investors
happy because the investors pump in more
money
so
where do things go from here
well
i have to imagine netflix is going to
have to start cutting some stuff back
like they can try all they want to crack
down on shared passwords add a fee to
that uh try and get people to subscribe
in a household where they're using a
borrowed account they'll get a little
but it's not going to be that much
i don't think it will be anyways not
enough to recover what they've lost in
terms of their
stock value because they've gone from
looking like the monolith going from
strength to strength and just look at it
go
up into the sky to the
moon but now
everybody sees the cracks in the armor
now it's like how are you gonna patch up
this boat
and they are probably gonna need
one to two years of solid super
sustained growth on whatever it is
they're going to do
to try and i don't mean stock growth i
mean growth of
revenue and or profit preferably both
they're going to need
one to two years solid increases on all
that
before their stock will really start to
recover from this because
right now it just looks like a leaky
ship
and
it's hard for companies to turn that
around when the thing that appears to
have sprung a leak is the fundamental
core of the business because you know
apple can lose stock because
a new iphone comes out and doesn't sell
what it's supposed to
they can they they would
but
like that's not all that they are
if netflix
has to admit to losing subscribers
that's what netflix is
that's the entire core of the of the
companies what everything is built on if
that's hemorrhaging
well as i said
stock buyers respond to the perception
and the perception
is that
parties over
the reality
who knows all that all that debt they've
run up
that has the potential to really bite
them in the ass am i
foretelling the doom of netflix
no
but their time as the monolith
is over and i don't think we're ever
going to see another streaming platform
become as monolithic as they were
because part of the thing with netflix
is for a while they were basically the
only game in town
everything used to be on netflix then
there was hulu and amazon prime disney
plus hbo max paramount plus
etc etc it's all been divided up now
there isn't a single thing that everyone
had there's nothing that's going to be
memeable like something like netflix and
chill was
will the company still be around oh yeah
for a while definitely because it's
still worth a lot of money
just um
not what it was appearing to be worth
a week and a half ago you know what
occurs to me it's kind of funny that i
mentioned barnes and noble before
because i almost kind of see netflix on
the same track
they'll still be around
but they're never going to be what they
were
that's my
broad prediction at this point
netflix
what are your thoughts on any of this
mess whatever it is drop something down
the comments let's talk about it like
share subscribe patreons i pay the bills
that's why i don't have to work that
sales job that i hated
worked at nine years hated it hated it
um any amount you're able to give there
is is immensely
helpful it's
it's a blessing to not have to hold down
a job like that anymore but even if you
can't
like share subscribe i'll help me out
there's links to other things that i do
i have books that i've written that are
available on amazon i'm on twitter i'm
on twitch
all those links are down in the
description but
don't worry too much about it
what i really want you to remember
is that you are beautiful
you are valid
and you are loved
you are the council i'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
council
is adjourned
[Music]
and credits i got to shout out my top
patreon supporters so thank you very
much to zubin lutfullah barack oliver
bean melinda walters lyotha boy tt for
nobulax the poodle idol tracy scrabbat
vincent paul bartolucci angry casper
adam lefty taylor shane ross robin moore
shayla gourley and brendan the rose
couldn't do it without you
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]